we are taking calls at 617-830-4750
just for kicks let's go to maybe a local
call from the 774
area code uh caller what's your name and
where are you calling from today
uh hi i'm emma and i'm calling from
worcester massachusetts
all right what's on your mind today
um so as it becomes increasingly evident
that trump will not last
all four years what are your thoughts on
mike pence becoming the president yeah
we were just talking about that i think
that the the scary thing about pence is
um number one he is just a down the line
religious conservative ideologue from
the midwest so
this is a guy who supported funeral
service mandatory funeral services after
a miscarriage for example
this is a guy who supports all all sorts
of forms of voter suppression
and actually understands how to make it
happen other than just going on twitter
and saying three to five million people
voted illegally
so the scary part of mike pence being
president is that
the sort of scandal nature of of the
the day-to-day scandals would probably
be dampened
pence would be way more effective at
doing really really horrible things
and people would probably unengage from
politics because you'd go back to having
basically like a george w
bush on steroids type point of view so
the only hope
pat would be that if there were to be a
removal of donald trump from office
that there would be no way to separate
to decouple trump and pence they would
have ideally both have been involved in
whatever it was that leads to trump's
resignation
so pence would also have to resign but
then you'd end up with paul ryan as
president
of the united states i mean none of it
paints a good picture i mean if you look
down that order then you have oren hatch
and all these republicans down the list
because of course they're in charge of
the entire executive branch right now
um yeah i think i i can boil it down
pretty simply to
pence would be worse when it comes to
social policy and trump is a lot worse
when it comes to foreign policy maybe
economic they're split so
it's kind of like you're picking your
poison yeah it's i think what you're
getting at emmett
is and correct me if i'm wrong that if
we get rid of
trump there's a whole new set of
disastrous potential
there yeah yeah and possibly one that's
that's probably worse for a lot of
people yeah no i don't disagree with you
that's a that's a serious thing
uh we will keep talking about appreciate
the call always great to hear from
fellow massachusetts listeners
and viewers